immediately you believe the Marvel Mars
rover is real is that what the [ __ ] is
going on with I don't know I don't think
there's a conspiracy in the conspiracy I
think maybe is a double negative I think
I can I got across
oh he's oh they're testing missiles did
you see that [ __ ] that's right
if seen the parade show Vic the clip of
the parade where they show them like the
soldiers marching it right in the next
lecture and then I bring out the
missiles they said the radio the viewers
okay show back and then they'll cut the
Jim Hong Wong or Jim Kim Jong hoon yeah
will general it's like there's a clip of
like like they're like no no I kind of
watching in their heads and then they
cut back to the parade and it's the same
clip and then they go back to Kim's
juice it just I don't know eating North
Korea's fake I'm not saying it's fake
I'm saying that it's fake
I miss Harriet Kim Jong rule could eat
but he might be hard I think they're all
buddies I think at the very top the top
of Russia at the top of the United
States the UK they're just putting on a
show and he's designated villain when we
need to distract people from this or
that [ __ ] he up kim jong hoon here's
a kill a lot of people testing testing
and missiles
testing missiles even though he's gonna
he's going to fire off one would but
anything on let's do do there's a lot of
people there I don't know how many
thousand that is but there's a lot of
people they put on shows for people
coming in you come in they're gonna put
a show on for you but not everywhere to
go right they're putting on so there's
actors everywhere already this is just a
lot of them I mean they don't hear you
probably [ __ ] he's probably legit but
we've been lied to so many without bail
like what's a lie
do all these people are actors and they
just live there they're all out under
they love but just think of how crazy
that is wouldn't it be more likely that
these poor people are just brainwashed
because we know people get brainwashed
well you know well you've made craziest
when you when you're taking into
consideration all the lies that we've
been told the faked moon missions and
all this [ __ ] nothing I mean this is
nothing they put together a bunch of
people and made a [ __ ] parade they
fake the moon mission six time but
everybody believes that [ __ ] but
I'm not saying they're actors I'm just
saying there's something fishy about the
whole North Korea of course I'm not
saying that they're act it could be
anything I'm just saying I don't know
I'm saying it's that smells fishy
something is not right about what
they're telling us about North Korea
it is a crazy little machine stuff big
ass but you're not buying that [ __ ]
Eddie you know he killed babies lotion
it's like man wow that's doing but
that's what I do though yes I went off
that's wrong no it's the biggest bomb
that ever has been dropped okay
in war outside of a nuclear bomb we
don't believe non-nuclear I don't
believe I do by aliens are crazy I am
tell me I'll uh I'm trying to figure out
what's the angle why are they showing us
this that's what I'm thinking that's how
crazy I am I'm [ __ ] sociopath
anything I want to become when it comes
to military [ __ ] that's blasted on the
History Channel or CNN I'm automatically
what's their angle I don't buy it
let me ask you to nail the conversation
sanity you need creativity dinosaurs I'm
crazy
dinosaurs real or not I don't trust that
[ __ ] you don't even do that I love that
Triceratops because everybody loves one
two Triceratops like Tyrannosaurus Rex
everybody's rooting for the tricep right
if you ruin for the Tyrannosaurus Rex in
an epic battle you're a douchebag right
you're right so you really like will do
what about the woolly mammoth um I I
would say yes
have you bought the [ __ ] elephant you
know maybe it's a [ __ ] elephant you
know Tyrannosaurus Rex there's no Bayard
I have to hit a new one was it going to
bring it back a lot of your threats is a
giant kangaroo that's what it is that's
my guess it looks exactly the same it's
got a tail hops around on two legs
Tyranno that's a [ __ ] they found a
giant kangaroo and when they figured it
out to go dude it's a kangaroo they like
to [ __ ] was that what about like the way
the earth is like the layers and can
tell with certain time kids from the
lives of Stratos I love well if you're
talking about carbon dating there's a
lot of science that goes back and forth
getting [ __ ] or it's real oh it's not no
there's no
most universally acknowledged carbon
dating is effective okay well not the
stuff that I'm looking into I don't know
haha why don't you have a show in the
Alex Jones channel what what is that
I agree we're [ __ ] I want you my total
[ __ ] on them I want full Flat Earth on
a platter
no no no most most conspiracy most
conspiracy or not baby there's Flat
Earth is the most [ __ ] targeting
ever when Joe Furman correct when Joe
first brought it up like a body about a
year year and a half ago he said dude he
was trying to he was trying to basically
say how stupid people are he said you
know people still believe the earth is
flat and the Sun is 3,000 miles away and
I remember sitting there thinking [ __ ]
that were the Amish or something like
how dumb do have to be world to my
videos later how does one not nothing
very far again and they were got it
again you brought it up again like maybe
six months later and I and I said and I
said on your podcast I said that's got
it that is so dumb that's got to be some
kind of CIA Scion I was trying to debunk
it I want any here's a [ __ ] Japanese
satellite it takes a photo from $22,000
every 10 minutes come on really
happening there's no doubt it's a class
though even if the pixels I'm left of
those pictures it does not support an
interest put up any Japanese it's from
22,000 miles away
what if you remember pictures do you
remember when you out of the little
phone I can't remember when you had a
flip phone dude there zgi composite so
constantly make it CGI and some sort of
custom link some sort of a copper bank
somewhere show me a repetition NASA does
not have one of those satellite fake why
do you think that's very efficient Hawk
why does it look say let's talk it looks
like something you'd see in a movie
that's because when they do it in a move
they try to make it look like this which
is what looks real
if that's real to you manse you don't
think it's really why would it be fake
propaganda man okay why would they care
that it's not very a photo of this Flat
Earth no I just said again look like
there's is there's no there's no photo
of of the Flat Earth from space there's
no photo of the round earth predators
that's not true
don't go goes why do you say they're
fake those what
they look fake they look CGI but you're
not an expert in imagery looks like
tomato when I watch avatar I already
like an expert to know what you wait
when I want you had a monarchs forever
so avatars at the movies why do you
always go towards the conspiracy why do
you never consider the possibilities in
mind but any nineteen people it's all
the same everybody mobile thing as all
the spate European Space Agency's line
they're all in on it
global thing so I think all of their I
think all governments but most of them
the globalist are working together to to
control their whatever you embarrass
everything the earlier I told you lazy
but what's the advance that's not loud I
within if the control you broke will
keep you wanna keep you on up there's I
don't know man I don't know what it
doesn't make sense why would you make
that why just control by level find out
all you could find the sound of the
real-time whether you put them on a ball
because again I'm crazy you put them on
a ball my gadget you're on a ball you're
nowhere don't try to go anywhere just
stay down there oh hell no I don't think
you're thinking correct I'm telling I
know that's why I've stated many times
that you're crazy but you're online when
you use it when do you think you started
losing it I think I was you know as soon
as I found out when I was 11 that
everybody wasn't Catholic I was that's
when I started losing my wait a minute
I'm like everybody's not Catholic I
thought everybody was sounds like
there's other religions and how do we
know we're right there's a bunch of it's
a Jew oh [ __ ] there's more Jews and
catkin Catholics how do we know we have
the right religion I'm like okay you saw
the website yes that's when I started
going great it's so funny there's a
bunch of different factions that you
call the government I have an idea that
it's all like the government can't be
trusted I just say that because I'm not
going to I mean I do want me to pick out
some agencies you got NASA I can pick
out some sudden air spectrum but just in
general in general its history science
education energy everything has always
been controlled by the government since
day one radio has been used as
propaganda since the day it was invented
you think some independent dude just
invented radio and then he started
broadcasting there like his favorite
music and [ __ ] and he what his thoughts
it was the government from day one in
radio it was the government in all
countries from day one in a TV in the
movies it was it was all radio TV and
the movies you have always been about
propaganda always in every country it's
nothing new there's a there was a war on
drugs we started war on drugs turns out
we're bringing it in then there's a war
on terrorism
turns out we created al-qaeda did you
understand why I'm crazy I'm crazy
because of that [ __ ] like you could
believe that [ __ ] you want to believe
that here's a good one I do just apply
this to everything basically and even
kinda governments and with incoming from
the government dinosaurs don't come from
the government just there's so much
fraud when you're looking at essentially
a government it comes at our sign to
look into it look into it but Eddie I
have looked into it look I'm just a kid
look this is you could you could go over
these different test results and of the
earth look you can look at the next one
that comes 10 minutes later maybe you
won't think that one's fake oh wow those
kind of reacts all fake if you look into
the experiments to prove that the earth
is spinning all of them failed look into
it what do you do I find second to this
day Einstein said it's totally noble is
that we're moving most famous failed
experiment that's the mechanism early
experiment I was on they couldn't
recreate it so this thing you keep
repeating is [ __ ] oh nothing you
keep it but don't no no as your did you
get this information
Jeff Jamie where'd you get it where'd I
get what this information what is this
coming from this is coming off the
internet
exactly Marian so whatever information
I'm bringing something for my journal oh
don't go to the library oh it's on
Wikipedia display we stopped three
sources here there's a book called the
American Journal of science I'm sure
that all children rich bought and paid
for
well maybe it is it's not very portable
part of our society
in fact the Washington potty you just
having turned this flat I didn't say
that I said I don't know but it's flat
or round when I see a picture of Earth
from space but we're sitting on from
space when I see a real picture then
we'll have the proof I'm just saying we
don't have no no Widow okay now find
that then the CG is already anything do
you believe anything I believe [ __ ] that
I can prove to myself like I believe the
science in like a skyscraper why because
I
skyscraper it's standing there that's
true but how am i believing how much
have you looked into like the science of
space travel how much have you looked
into how much work was done to try to
put satellites into orbit so you think
we went to the moon that's not what I
asked you I said how much did you leave
Italy went to the moon heady answer my
[ __ ] to my talk ridiculous so you're
trying circle okay you're talking in
circles
I am the ridiculous conversations
everything is the government the
government the government the
government's fake pictures largest
athlete question bunch of NASA CGI
artists picture of Earth I don't see
that up there okay so where's the let's
get to some photoshop find the one where
he's talking okay but this guy's talking
about science here like some of the
science has to be real right Eddie but
there has to be some saddle it's like
DirecTV DirecTV is not fake right um I
don't know I don't know but you could do
all that with landline stuff you don't
need to go balance anything from space
you could do all that long why wouldn't
you you could just put it in space and
it just broadcast you shoot it up there
and shoot it back why would you lie
about that I mean there's a ton the
[ __ ] space junk like Johnny maddick
teymourian
the second they satellite you know days
for satellites no place for satellites
the taxpayer they get bills we need news
telecommunication satellite we got to
throw it up there so you don't need 35
million dollars don't think oh yeah okay
we refine it they get the money tax cam
you don't think satellites are real I
don't think so dude that was using the
moon landing for Joe gigantic and so
global and the greatest achievement
mankind and they don't even have the
records anymore Joe you know what I'm
talking about we're talking about this
earlier man you were talking about this
early you know all that moon you know
immature data's missing yeah yeah so you
know we had an awesome video says he
says yeah we don't have it it's missing
or maybe it's stolen but even if we did
the head of NASA even if we did have the
tapes we don't have the machines to play
them anymore so it really doesn't matter
come on man come on man a dumbass [ __ ]
detective on the planet what would be
suspicious maybe they did say that but
you can't just lump and I'm like saying
they did the greatest achievement of
mankind
time then if we hang a lot but I'm not
Major Lazer that we have new people now
come on Gloria you can all go out can
can you see how I can't trust [ __ ] from
acid but it's not fair you stick with
your life so I'm gonna take a little
jiggle maybe that would they they you
know all those bad people have died and
they're old and the new NASA there's a
good NASA they can't all going to blast
I'm just having fun what do you think is
the earth flat around I don't know if
it's flat around until we see a picture
from space
they say that [ __ ] could be squared I
don't know what it would you turn around
it could be windy well a very camera
with fish I'd fish I bet you guys are
fooled by the fisheye lens come on now
many pages without the precise legs that
you could find the fish I'd lend you go
to understand perspective basic
ass-kicking the guard you understand
perspective it's lighter because we're
in the atmosphere of Earth isn't it less
dense than if we were in space there is
no atmosphere
that's why everything floats gasses and
us we're dense too but we would float in
space like that if you do splits we got
into space you're correct if we got out
there so believe that can we not go to
space I don't know how far we can go up
oh yeah you know the space station on
Jerry said the Space Shuttle went into
orbit I don't know how far one day we're
pretty hot I don't know where ever you
know I knew it I know it took off all
that okay and then I see it landing you
see that right you know know where I
went
you know when wait I'm gonna plane right
problem for sure I worry about Yeti I
really do you don't need to man I'm
[ __ ] group better than ever no you
have no idea I worry about you going
down this rabbit hole - what it what
what's the big deal who cares if the
earth is round or flat it's entertaining
to me I understand so why was it really
you very what shares of kid yeah if kids
start looking in the Flat Earth good
start questioning [ __ ] if you look into
it you and you have proof that it is
round instead of going oh some
scientists figure it out somebody
figured it out somebody figured out but
you you figure it out you try to figure
it out there flying unicorns bro the
grandmas flying unicorn I haven't even
told you the crazy [ __ ]
and then I'd never do a father-son I
haven't you know crazy wife [ __ ] I'll
tell you crazy bit louder crazier than
flattered why save it I don't come on
all my mind up you wanna marry me
come on I've already make in front of me
from flattered
I just I just don't I just don't trust
math I don't try and steal you know
social trust want to hear some crazy
[ __ ] please do promise I'll end on this
yeah listen
okay no oh she sure for next time yeah
just don't make it long right now we're
going off yeah you know if you drop it
now we'll never make progress and cut
it's six o'clock I know I just want to
okay yeah it's o'clock yeah unless
unless you want to hear it now I don't
know it's too crazy it's too crazy
go do it let's go crazy okay it's not
really really crazy thought we'll talk
off here by little bit aggression hey
Heather so crazy it will discredit the
Flat Earth theory okay my mind can't
handle daddy everything is I left this
one Union jazz everything is conspiracy
you make life but you know you'll make
Alex Jones look like [ __ ] like Gandhi
[ __ ] like like Guy Fawkes Jones is
what Alex Jones like 90% of conspiracy
theories like well that's all [ __ ]
you know but Eddie just peacefully and
you you got appreciate the hustle by
Eddie time Alex Jones is like up the
weirdo Percy says you have the wow I
can't believe you said that to end on
that
[Applause]
[Music]